I understand what the Duke and Duchess
of Sussex feel about press intrusion and
criticism of their lives but I'm afraid
in 21st century Britain it comes with
the territory
you can argue it shouldn't but it
inevitably does and I also understand
why the Duke blames the paparazzi for
the death of his mother and fears it
might happen again the trouble is what
does he do about it well it could be
that Harry and Megan will only get the
sort of life they want by leaving the UK
and leading a more private life in
Africa one of Pitts Harry's favorite
places or in the USA where his wife
comes from it doesn't need to be a big
deal or a great drama how he is sixth in
line to the throne so he won't be
creating a constitutional crisis like
his great-great uncle did when he
abdicated he might just choose like many
Brits do these days that he and his wife
would have a better life living overseas
Harry and Megan living aboard will be a
loss to the royal family but the House
of Windsor has survived much bigger
crises I think watching that documentary
what became there's a lot of things
became clear to me one that Harry to me
looks like he's unraveling it's also
clear from the comments that wills made
a day later that um the the rift that
the press were all blamed for making up
is very real and very deep and that the
pair of them aren't talking to each
other at all and I think because of that
I think because Harry has become
separated from his family and seems it
seems to be you know just camp him and
Megan it's them against the rest of the
world he's lost all perspective on
things now I think this is part of the
problem
there was one quote that really got me
said every flash every camera click
takes me back 22 years well you know
that I think is incredibly disturbing
because and actually I just want to say
this before anybody else comes in Jane
where a colleague of ours and a very
good friend of ours kind of sum this up
in her column yesterday and she said
that you know he hadn't dealt properly
with the death of his mom over the past
few years but what's happened since
she's met someone that he loves and he
treasures and now has a child he cares
about them every bit as much as he cared
about his mom
and he has this irrational fear that
he's going to lose them both
and and it's I just think it's I I just
think it's he looks like he's unraveling
because of that I think it's very hard
for a lot of people to record to
reconcile her standing in a backdrop of
South Africa with six million kids are
starving where they have the lowest life
expectancy rate well it is on the
planets and talk about her first world
problems should if you're campaigning
for people whose situations are a
million times worse than theirs I I
believe in the old maxim don't kick a
bloke when he's down and I think this
bloke is down at the moment I think
you're right in what you say I wonder if
he's ever ever fully come to terms of
the grief what we have witnessed is that
he was a real rambunctious army boy
wasn't he playing one of Greg's favorite
grains strip billiards which I know
you're a tremendous well one of the
world champions and do you know that
living the life of a soldier boy falling
in and out and I don't say this
disparaging you doing what young men do
different number of girlfriends lovely
falling in and out of nightclubs then he
finds love and nation celebrates just
over a year ago and something something
has gone wrong and I wonder whether one
aspect is and here we look at what
William has achieved with Kate or the
Duke and Duchess of Cambridge in Kate
Middleton she has a tremendous bedrock
of a family all the jokes that were made
about about Kate's mum all the jokes
made about that and her background that
family you can see are rock-solid sadly
Megan's family is a little dysfunctional
so he hasn't got that to go to his own
family he has an interesting
relationship obviously with his father
because the marriage went out the way it
did I don't think you can say that
William and Harry aren't talking at all
certainly when you talk about the
majority of the time we're okay that
means the majority of the time you're
not they need this six-week break and
what Harry has to realize and I say this
from the heart having covered more
Royals and you can have off dinners the
nation loves this bloke we want you to
be well if you need 12 weeks off take 12
weeks off and come back what the Harry
that we want to see and love Greg out of
respect for you in this debate I lost an
hour of my life last night it's watching
this ITV documentary because I must be
honest I'm not particularly interested
in the royal family so it's not the kind
of thing that I would have watched if we
weren't debating it today and
I found it quite interesting to watch
and I would just pick up on something
that you just said you said that she's
in South Africa where people are she's
basically like a million times better
and a better place and lots of the
people but what I would say is the
challenge with mental health and it
doesn't care whether you're up here or
down there no what I'm saying is I'm
talking about because there's been a lot
of criticism on these two people about
well how can they be down on how can
they be frustrated because they've got
this they've got that they have all this
so that was the first point I wanted to
make that whether whether you're rich or
poor or in the middle or your mental
health challenges don't recognize or
discriminate about that as the first
point the second point is I always when
I think of William and Harry I think of
them as little boys particularly Harry
walking behind their mom's coffin no but
those kind of thing is whoever thought
that that was a good idea to make those
little boys what we hunt their mom's
coffin it's beyond me and since they you
know they have got so much focus on them
and what I don't discern and I agree
with you if you don't like it or it's
not what you want or it's causing you
distress they are in the the good
position to be able to step away from
that and I think that if it is causing
them angst and all the rest of it then
there really should go and think about
their other option that's what I'm I'm
incredibly sympathetic to both of them
and where they find themselves yes I'm
facing them if mine is not saying clear
up - saying if you're if you're
struggling to cope you need to do
something else and it might be yeah and
you and it might be you have to go
aboard to get that sort of freedom to
get the sudden away from the pressure
that you're never really going to be in
this country I mean oh well Prince
William had a better time when he was
doing a day job essentially and he said
that it was it was rewarding when I come
here to do this job I really I really
look forward to coming here every day
whether it's 5:30 a.m. or going to bed
at 2 in the morning the shift work is
exciting it's challenging it's a variety
it's more than anything that's somebody
who enjoys somebody so there there are
other lives that they could lead right
if they go to the Bahamas do they
renounce the jus of the titles they just
become Harry and
money they've got plenty money is not
what it's about it's about you want to
give them the opportunity to world as a
family to get together without feeling
under the sort of pressure and he
clearly I mean that line in that
documentary that said that line and then
talking with it said and it showed quite
clearly what you what your calm is said
that actually didn't get over his
mother's twenty and you wouldn't think
so if you you know the family itself
didn't help him so it didn't know what
about the statement he made the
following day way he said there was a
there was a quote where they said that
they had single-handedly modernized the
monarchy when I was talking before about
how I think they've both lost
perspective Palace I didn't carry nor
Megan said that
so it's unfair to attribute that to
either of the couple everything we have
is a source I mean the two boys have
nice and loyal family but so is the
Queen this is a huge insult Queen what
she was about the Queen still runs a
Victorian okay let me tell you how ten
years ago Megan would not have not been
able to marry Harry because ten years
ago an American divorcee of mixed race
would not have been allowed to marry
Harry that's that's the modernize it
wasn't the Queen Mary Taggart Megan but
she but she allowed that to happen the
Queen what I'm telling you is the Queen
has modernized the monarchy wills has
modernized the monarchy in exactly his
air and how are you going on the front
lines sorry for me but how are we going
on the front that actually facing day
that is tremendous I know his uncle did
it I know Andrew did it it's fantastic
for me it's sorry the idea that you can
attribute the modernization of having
people that aren't Royals and the royal
family of people who've met ethnic back
and minority ethnic backgrounds in the
world family example and attribute that
to the Queen you're probably half my age
you're about a quarter of his age
goodness what was it to you and your but
do you ever talk about them idem in this
route I'm really do you ever talk about
the royal family or are they effectively
meaningless possibly once a year I just
best like no and what would it be a
romance or a marriage or it'll be
whenever whenever they produce a child
or anything like that yeah
the other than that the royal family
does not really exist in our discussions
at all
and we'd love the I mean me personally I
love the fact that we have a queen and
she's a great symbol part of her
identity but no it's not huge it's not
the greatest even which is held clearly
[Laughter]
important part of our national isn't he
said the Queen wasn't responsible for
the modernization of the royal family
which i think is right but I would I
would say that we need to recognize the
fact that as you said before emotion
does not see privilege if you've got if
you've if you've lost your mum that is
something that will affect anybody
regardless of what piles they happen to
live in and right now Meghan for example
she's a new mother and I think it would
be nice if the if the Presto could
convince of the fact that she's dealing
with the idea of I'm just just trying to
relieve the new child